[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis einen schönen guten Abend
wünsche ich ihnen Fußball gleich von
Norbert Lehmann
die großen Themen in dieser Sendung
neue Regierung in Italien die
ultra-rechte Georgia Meloni ist die
erste Ministerpräsidentin in der
Geschichte des Landes
Solidarität mit iran-protesten
zehntausende demonstrieren in Berlin
gegen das mula-regime auch im Iran geht
der Widerstand weiter
und wird das Buch ein Luxusgut die
Verlage auf der Buchmesse hoffen dass
die Kunden trotz Inflation dem Buch
weiter treu bleiben
[Musik]
in Italien sind mit Georgia Meloni an
der Spitze erstmals seit Diktator
Mussolini wieder ultra-rechte an der
Macht Meloni wurde heute als
Ministerpräsidentin vereidigt ihre
Partei fratelli d'Italia hat
faschistische Wurzeln
Meloni war schon als Jugendliche bei den
Neofaschisten aktiv ihr Aufstieg ist eng
mit Silvio Berlusconi verbunden er
machte die gebürtige Römerin 2018
jugendministerin gemeinsam mit ihm und
Matthäus Salvini hat sie das
rechtsbündnis geschmiedet mit dem sie
nun regieren wird Andreas poste stellt
die neue Regierung vor
auf diesen Moment hat sich Georgia
melloni lange vorbereitet die
Parteichefin der Ultra rechten fratelli
d'Italia mit neofaschistischen Wurzeln
wird als erste Regierungschefin Italiens
vereidigt den Amtseid kann sie auswendig
die Treue zu halten die Verfassung und
die Gesetze zu beachten und mein Amt
ausschließlich im Interesse der Nation
auszuüben
in der neuen Regierung hat ihre Partei
mit neun posten die meisten Minister die
ebenfalls weiter rechtsstehende Lager
und die konservative Forza Italia
erhielten hier 5 in den Tagen zuvor gab
es noch Streit um die Kabinettsposten
überschattet von Putin freundlichen
Aussagen Silvio Berlusconis seine Forza
Italia wird nun von Antonio Tajani dem
neuen Außenminister und vizeprämie
vertreten zweite regierungsvize wird
Matthäus Salvini er bekommt aber von
Meloni nicht das prestigeträchtige
Innenministerium sondern das Ministerium
für Verkehr und Infrastruktur
auch so wird von Italien zukünftig eine
härtere antimigrationspolitik erwartet
außerdem hat das rechte
Regierungsbündnis ihrer Wählerschaft
eine law and order Politik versprochen
nach dem Motto Italien
zuersto sie haben eine sehr wütende
Wählerschaft die den Institutionen sehr
feindlich gegenübersteht aber es sind
auch wohlhabende Leute die Geschäfte und
wirtschaftliche Unternehmen haben mit
anderen Worten keine revolutionäre
sondern bürgerliche Leute ohne Interesse
ihr Land in die Luft zu jagen
im Rekordtempo von nur vier Wochen hat
Meloni ihr Regierungsbündnis
zusammenbekommen morgen wird die
45-Jährige von Mario Draghi die
Amtsgeschäfte übernehmen und in Rom mit
dem regieren beginnen
Andreas Postel in Rom was bedeutet die
neue Rechte Regierung in Italien für die
EU
am deutlichsten wird man das in Europa
sicherlich in einer deutlich härteren
Gangart bei der Migrationspolitik sehen
da sind Meloni und Salvini schon im
Wahlkampf sehr sehr klar gewesen und
insgesamt werden die Hardliner in Europa
wie Ungarn oder Polen sicherlich jetzt
einen starken Partner an ihre Seite
bekommen immerhin die drittgrößte
Volkswirtschaft Europas
was die Haltung zur Ukraine und zum
Ukraine Krieg und zu Russland anbelangt
da ist die Regierung schon deutlich
uneinheitlicher Georgia milioni steht da
zwar aufgrund ihrer Nähe zur polnischen
peace-partei klar zu Waffenlieferung an
die Ukraine aber ihre Koalitionspartner
sind in der Vergangenheit deutlich
Russland freundlicher aufgefallen Silvio
Berlusconi freute sich jüngst über 20
vodka-flaschen zu seinem Geburtstag von
seinem Freund Wladimir Putin da kann man
gespannt sein wie der jetzt zur
italienischen Regierungsübernahme
gratuliert und Georgia miloni sah sich
gezwungen da jetzt deutlich Signale zu
setzen nach Europa man stehe zu seinen
Bündnisverpflichtungen in Europa und zur
NATO der werden also die europäischen
Partner jetzt sehr wachsam sein müssen
ob da Wort und Tat zusammen passenden
Zukunft in Italien danke Einschätzung
andreasspostel
in Berlin haben sich nach Polizeiangaben
rund 80.000 Menschen bei einer
Demonstration mit den Protesten im Iran
solidarisiert darunter auch viele Exil
Iranerinnen und Iraner seit dem Tod
einer 22-jährigen nach der Festnahme
durch die Sittenpolizei gehen im Iran
Menschen auf die Straße ihr Slogan
Frauen Leben Freiheit wir schauen gleich
in den Iran vorher ein Bericht über die
Solidaritätsdemonstration in Berlin von
Lisa Jandi und Carsten Behrendt
Frau Leben Freiheit der Ruf der
iranischen Protestbewegung heute in der
deutschen Hauptstadt zehntausende sind
gekommen die Veranstalter sprechen von
der größten Demo aller Zeiten außerhalb
Irans gegen das Regime
ich bin aus Dänemark als Stimme des Iran
ich komme aus Norwegen ein weiter Weg
aber das muss sein für das iranische
Volk
Heil von Iran und Iran ist ein Teil von
mir dafür muss man kämpfen Hamed
ismaelion ist aus Kanada angereist der
Zahnarzt und Autor gilt als Initiator
der Proteste außerhalb Irans vor knapp
drei Jahren wurden seine Frau und
Tochter getötet in einer
Passagiermaschine abgeschossen vom
iranischen Militär
ist für alle ein symbolischer Ort hier
wurde die Mauer eingerissen und wir
hoffen dass auch die Mauern im Iran
fallen werden und die Menschen den
Berliner Beispiel folgen
es soll ein Weckruf sein auch für die
Europäische Union und die
Bundesregierung Deutschland ist der
wichtigste Handelspartner des Iran
es reicht nicht dass man sagt dass man
nur hinter uns steht im Iran oder hinter
den Frauen es ist wichtig was zu tun
dass die Müllers weggehen und die Frauen
aber natürlich auch die Männer alle
freien Iran leben können wir fordern die
deutsche Politik dass die jegliche
diplomatische und politische Beziehungen
mit den touristischen Regime von Iran
aufbrechen
[Applaus]
zehntausende Stimmen für den Iran ein
lautstarker und friedlicher Aufschrei
aus Berlin
im Iran selbst gibt es seit fünf Wochen
jeden Tag Proteste gegen das molaregim
das lässt mit Gewalt gegen die
Demonstrierenden Vorgehen nach Angaben
von Menschenrechtsorganisationen sind
bereits mehr als 200 Menschen getötet
worden und tausende inhaftiert aus
Teheran Jörg
von Tag zu Tag werden es mehr Frauen
ohne Kopftuch in den Straßen Teherans
als wir eine von ihnen interviewen
wollen erkennt eine andere unser
zdf-mikrofon und ruft auf deutsch
Liebe Freiheit
iranische Frauen wütend und mutig wir
wollen das Gespräch fortsetzen doch
sofort hält ein Motorrad
Sicherheitskräfte beenden unser Internet
in diesen Tagen sind es zunehmend
Aktionen zivilen Ungehorsams Graffitis
hochkonzerte auf den Straßen
regimekritische Rufer aus den Fenstern
am Abend ein Schlag auf den Turban eines
Geistlichen die Solidarität im Ausland
macht ihnen Mut
das hilft uns hundertprozentig sagt
diese junge Frau die nicht erkannt
werden will diese Aktionen helfen dass
unsere Stimmen in der ganzen Welt gehört
werden so etwas hat es bisher noch nicht
gegeben die Behörden wollen die Lage
beruhigen bestrafen die Frauen ohne
Kopftuch in diesen Tagen nicht doch das
kann die protestierende nicht überzeugen
für den Abend haben Studenten zu
weiteren Demonstrationen in Teheran und
anderen Städten im Land aufgerufen
obwohl die Teilnehmerzahlen seit Wochen
eher stagnieren bleibt die
Protestbewegung hier in Iran trotzdem
weiter aktiv aktuelle Bilder aus Desue
im Südwesten ein paar hundert rufen
ihren Landsleuten zu Iraner unterstützt
uns weil ihr euer Land liebt
in China hat Staatschef schising Ping
seine Macht auf dem Parteikongress
weiter ausgebaut zum Abschluss der
Veranstaltung vor ankerten die
Delegierten schieß dauerhafte
Führungsrolle in der Verfassung der
Kommunistischen Partei morgen dürfte der
69-Jährige für eine dritte Amtszeit
bestätigt werden
am Rande kam es zu einem Zwischenfall um
den früheren Staatschef husin Tao er
wurde offenbar gegen seinen Willen aus
dem Saal gebracht who gilt als Kritiker
der aktuellen Führung
im Kampf um die Nachfolge der britischen
Premierminister und Trust von mir ihren
sich die Lager als Favorit gilt
Ex-Finanzminister Richi suneck er soll
bereits die erforderliche Unterstützung
von mindestens 100 konservativen
Abgeordneten haben aber auch ein
Comeback von Boris Johnson scheint
möglich der Ex-Premier kehrte heute
früher aus dem Urlaub zurück auch er
soll bereits ausreichend Unterstützer
und UnterstützerInnen haben
angesichts des Vormarsches der
ukrainischen Armee hat die von Russland
eingesetzte Verwaltungen hassonne die
Zivilbevölkerung dazu aufgerufen die
Stadt sofort zu verlassen die Menschen
müssten umgehend bootsüberfahrten über
den dinni Pro nutzen und sich tiefer in
Russisch kontrolliertes Territorium
begeben erklärten die Behörden im
Online-Netzwerk telegram die
Evakuierungen über den Fluss sind seit
Mittwoch im Gang
in der Ukraine soll es auch heute wieder
massive russische Angriffe auf die
Energieinfrastruktur gegeben haben laut
Präsidialamt haben inzwischen mehr als
eine Million Haushalte keinen Strom mehr
hinzu kommen geplante Abschaltungen um
das Netz im Land einigermaßen stabil zu
halten daran hassanzaded berichtet
fast 3000 Haushalte hängen an diesem
Verteiler in Kiew von Norden Elektriker
machen im Winter Fest soll der Strom wie
es jetzt geschieht kontrolliert
abgeschaltet werden dann gelingt dies
nur über diese kleinen Stationen
tausende verteilt im ganzen Land es ist
ein Wettlauf ukrainische Elektriker
gegen russische Luftangriffe
wir sind da wo wir sein müssen wir
verteidigen unsere Front im energiekrieg
wir werden bis zum Ende kämpfen während
der Wartungsarbeiten wurde der Strom im
Viertel abgestellt für die Anwohner ein
erster Vorgeschmack auf den Winter
wenn wir im Zimmer spielen dann machen
wir das Licht an wenn wir rausgehen
wieder auszusparen wir Energie für mich
ist es nicht so wichtig ob ich Strom
habe oder nicht ich gehe um 8 Uhr ins
Bett
als mich am härtesten trifft das Essen
aufzubewahren wenn der Kühlschrank
ausfällt beim größten Energieversorger
der Ukraine sieht man das nicht so
entspannt der Vorstand fürchtet einen
Systemabsturz deshalb wird im ganzen
Land gestaffelt und gezielt der Strom
für einige Stunden abgeschaltet
wenn die Energieversorger nicht den
Verbrauch und die Produktion angleichen
dann könnte dies zu einem Ausfall des
Stromsystems führen zu einem totalen
Stromausfall dazu kommt dass menschliche
Leid 85 Mitarbeiter hat Dimitri als
Soldaten im Krieg verloren sieben durch
russische Luftangriffe am Arbeitsplatz
Kraftwerke müssen immer not besetzt sein
selbst bei Luftalarm
hier bei uns wird weiter diskutiert wann
die gaspreisbremse zu kommen soll
Kanzler scholz sagte dazu heute vor
Handwerkern und Handwerkerinnen in
München er wolle einen möglichen
Starttermin 1 Januar ausloten dazu
müssen man sich aber erstmal mit den
Energieversorgern beraten man könnte das
nicht einfach beschließen es bräuchte
einen großen Schulterschluss und den
organisiere man gerade
die hohen Preise für Energie- und
Lebensmittel bringen viele Menschen zur
Zeit in Not bundesweit demonstrierten
daher heute tausende Menschen für mehr
soziale Gerechtigkeit die meisten kamen
in Berlin zusammen mehr von Anja Chalet
solidarisch durch den Herbst unter
diesem Motto zogen tausende durch das
Berliner Regierungsviertel aufgerufen
hatte das bündnissolidarische Herbst ein
Zusammenschluss von Gewerkschaften
sozial und Umweltverbänden die
Forderungen sozial und Klimakrise nicht
gegeneinander ausspielen eine stärkere
Besteuerung von vermögenden und
Unternehmen wir endlich und wirkungsvoll
denen helfen die es wirklich brauchen
und das ist nun mal die unteren 50% in
diesem Lande das sind Menschen die von
Hartz IV leben von Altersgrundsicherung
Leben das sind aber auch die ganz viele
die Arbeiten gehen ihren
Erwerbseinkommen haben aber trotzdem bei
diesem Preisen kaum mehr über die Runden
kommt Situation ist so zugespitzt und
viele Menschen haben die sorgen dass sie
über den Winter nicht gut kommen die die
es brauchen sollten mehr kriegen als die
die noch genug haben auch in Dresden
kamen die Menschen zahlreich zum Protest
für soziale Gerechtigkeit und gegen eine
Spaltung der Gesellschaft
da war ich ganz wichtiges Zeichen finde
die Straße nicht den Rechten zu
überlassen die versuchen die die Leute
abzufischen ein Protest ohne Hass und
Hetze die Veranstalter sprachen von
einem starken zivilgesellschaftlichen
Zeichen
auf der Frankfurter Buchmesse kommt am
Samstag traditionell das größte Publikum
auf dem Bühnen und an den Ständen sind
dann auch immer viele Prominente zu Gast
der erste Zwischenbilanz der
Veranstalter fällt positiv aus nach zwei
pandemiejahren in den die Messe nur
eingeschränkt stattfinden konnte Inken
Klinge
es ist wieder richtig voll so wie vor
der Pandemie und gerade auch junge Leute
interessieren sich fürs Buch und die
Autorinnen und Autoren auf der Messe
viele Promis stellen ihr neuestes Werk
vor die Hollywood-Schauspielerin Diane
Krüger hat einen Kinderbuch über Namen
geschrieben auch für ihre Tochter Nova
Tennessee ich hoffe dass wenn sie älter
wird dass sie oder sie ist vier jetzt
also ich habe ich lese hier das Buch
natürlich auch vor dass sie weiß wie
sehr wir über ihren Namen nachgedacht
haben wie sehr wir uns gefreut haben ein
ganz besonderes Projekt für ukrainische
Flüchtlingskinder präsentieren die
beiden first Ladies Elke Büdenbender und
Olena selenska Kinderbücher in
ukrainischer und deutscher Sprache die
jeder spenden kann Beta time Stories
Geschichten über bessere Zeiten
die Buchbranche insgesamt ist
optimistisch aber auch angespannt
besonders wegen steigender Papierpreise
auch Bücher könnten deutlich teurer
werden das Lesepublikum hier würde
trotzdem nicht ganz verzichten wollen
wenn sie natürlich teurer werden dann
werde ich vielleicht das eine oder
andere dann nicht kaufen oder ein
bisschen weniger kaufen aber Bücher sind
einfach mein Leben brauche ich man kann
ja auch e-reading machen also das würde
ich dann wahrscheinlich ja würde ich
dann umsteigen darauf Krimis und
Thriller bleiben beliebt in der
Neuerscheinung von Bestsellerautor
Sebastian Fitzek geht es um eine
Expertin für Mimik
Körpersprache ist eine Sprache die wir
alle sprechen keiner hat richtig gelernt
und wir deuten sie häufig falsch und das
hat mich einfach interessiert die größte
Buchmesse der Welt morgen hat sie noch
geöffnet
und jetzt kommen wir zur Fußball-WM der
Frauen da wurden heute in Auckland die
deutschen gruppengegnerin ausgelost
Norbert richtig ja und wie sagt man doch
so schön lösbare Aufgaben für das Team
von Martina Forst Tecklenburg mit
Kolumbien Südkorea und WM-Neuling
Marokko der ist auch der erste Gegner am
24 Juli alle deutschen spiele übrigens
in Australien
die Aufführung der indigenen Völker
Australiens und Neuseelands stimmt ein
auf die große Vorfreude in beiden
Ländern für die WM vom 20 Juli bis 20
August 2023 die Bundestrainerin
zufrieden mit der Auslosung der
bezwingbaren Gegner Marokko Kolumbien
und Südkorea die sogar schon einen Blick
auf die Zeit nach der Gruppenphase
zulässt dann gucken wir natürlich schon
ein bisschen weiter Richtung
Achtelfinale und das wird dann schon
eine große Herausforderung gegen die
Gruppe F wo vermeintlich natürlich mit
Frankreich und Brasilien schon auch ja
nicht nur vermeintlich sondern mit
Sicherheit Top-Teams sind
für die Bundestrainerin und ihr
Organisationsteam geht die Reise jetzt
nach Australien um nach einem passenden
Quartier für die deutsche Mannschaft zu
suchen
in der Fußball-Bundesliga der Männer hat
der BVB wieder Anschluss an die
Tabellenspitze durch einen souverän Sieg
gegen den VfB mit einem Doppelpack von
Jude Bellingham hier die bisherigen
Ergebnisse des 11 Spieltags Dortmund
Stuttgart 5:0 Augsburg verspielt eine
3:0 Führung gegen Leipzig RB gleich in
der 90 Minute aus entstand 3:3
Leverkusen Wolfsburg ebenfalls
unentschieden 2:2 Freiburg schlägt
Bremen 2:0 Hoffenheim unterliegt den
Bayern mit 0:2 und das Abendspiel
Gladbach gegen Frankfurt bereits gestern
besiegte Mainz den ersten fC Köln mit
5:0
die Tabelle Union spielt erst morgen
bleibt aber an diesem Spieltag auf jeden
Fall erster dahinter weiterhin die
Bayern auf dem zweiten und die
Freiburger auf dem dritten Platz
Dortmund klettert von Rang 8 auf Rang 4
für Mainz geht es hoch auf Platz 5
Hoffenheim 06 die zweite Hälfte beginnt
mit Köln ja und am Tabellenende Rutsch
Stuttgart auf den 16 Platz dahinter
Schalke und Schlusslicht Bochum
das Abendspiel Gladbach gegen Frankfurt
ausführlich bei uns zu sehen im
Aktuellen Sportstudio um 23 Uhr zu Gast
Aaron Seidel von Gladbachs
pokalbezwinger Darmstadt 98
der deutsche handballmeister SC
Magdeburg ist in Saudi-Arabien ins
Finale der Club WM eingezogen gegen den
ägyptischen Rekordmeister alachi überrag
den der ersten Hälfte der Magdeburger
magnussson mit sechs Treffern zur
knappen 18 zu 17 Halbzeitführung die
Mannschaft von Benet Wicker zog dann
aber unwiderstehlich davon
hochkonzentriert das ganze Team des
Titelverteidigers am Ende dann ein
klarer 36 zu 28 erfolgt Magdeburg trifft
morgen Abend im Finale entweder auf dem
polnischen Club kelze oder auf Barcelona
das war es vom Sport Dankeschön
auch morgen gibt es wieder Temperaturen
um 20 Grad mehr zu dieser oktoberwärme
gleichem Wetter mit Christa Orden das
heute schon mal können Sie um 22 Uhr
sehen mit Marietta Slomka auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend der Tiefe Luftdruck über dem
Atlantik hat sich richtig festgefahren
und so kommt auch erst einmal weiter
ungebrochen milde Luft aus dem Südwesten
bei uns an morgen ist es dazu meist
freundlich erst nachmittags erreicht uns
hier die warmen Front eines neuen Tiefs
heute Nacht ziehen erstmal letzte shower
im Ostsee Umfeld ab dann klart es oft
auf gebietsweise gibt es morgens aber
dichten Nebel davor kühlt es ab auf
Werte zwischen 9 und 5 Grad an der See
und im Westen bleibt es zweistellig
morgen ist es für die meisten ähnlich
mild wie heute auf Rügen gibt es 16
sonst um 20 Grad stellenweise wird es
aber noch mal etwas wärmer zum Beispiel
im Markgräflerland und in den föhntälern
denn der Wind dreht auf Süd es gibt
Föhnsturm in den Alpen sonst haben wir
einen frischen Südwind vormittags gibt
es den zehsnebel im Südosten wenn der
sich aufgelöst hat wechselt sich die
Herbstsonne mit Wolken ab im Westen da
sind die Wolken schon etwas dichter mit
einzelnen Schauern die kommen
nachmittags nach Osten voran abends sind
auch einzelne Gewitter mit dabei
deutlich unbeständiger wird es in der
Nacht zu und am Montag besonders im
Süden ist es dann regnerisch mit
Gewittern am Dienstag und am Mittwoch
ist es aber schon wieder überwiegend
trocken und auch in der neuen Woche gibt
es Höchstwerte über 20 Grad und damit
könnte dieser Oktober der mildeste seit
Aufzeichnungsbeginn werden tschüss